was it hard when you because like I feel
like you were buzzing and then obviously
you had to go sit down that was horrible
man hell yeah it was [ __ ] hard you
almost feel like that was like was there
was there a something positive you could
have took out of there like maybe you
weren't ready for the for the shine that
was coming at the time it was yeah
Looking Back Now definitely I had a lot
more living to do you know I mean a lot
of more ex things to experience I had to
get more of an understanding of business
I realized I ain't want to come in the
game that way yeah you know what I'm
saying I didn't want to be that kind of
artist you know I wanted to come into
the game a certain kind of way which was
going to take a certain kind of Route
certain type of time so look I didn't
know that at the beginning you know I
wanted to get right to where I was going
right then and there skip the steps yeah
but the steps you got to do with this
[ __ ] to make sure that you you know is
solid when you get there yeah so did you
feel like um because I feel like
sometimes artists make a mistake
when they're kind of like one foot in
one foot out on the rap [ __ ] where it's
like did that force you to kind of
really focus on music more take it a lot
more serious when you got out of course
like I had to make a conscious decision
and [ __ ] like whatever I want to do and
uh
prior to me making that decision I
always gave most of my energy to the
streets as opposed to
music you know even like the titles of
your early projects were like right it
was uh you know out on out on bail in
custody yeah I'm sorry right [ __ ] like
that 38 laws of powder
but
yeah I'm high as [ __ ] what was the
question I was just I was just saying
like you know obviously a lot of artists
come into the game and they have one
foot and one foot out like I feel like
sometimes you you have a humbling
experience like getting locked up where
you know might maybe kind of
reprioritize how you see things yeah of
course man see it like a lot of a lot of
people I could cause right yeah of
course so a lot of [ __ ] is
running around taking extreme risks and
[ __ ] like that because they never
suffered any consequences you know the
younger you are the more Wilder you are
moving recklessly because you know you
really ain't experienced any
consequences and [ __ ] me I'm a person
that experience consequence without the
consequence which makes me appreciate
not having that face consequences you
know what I'm saying 100 so until you
experience those consequences you're not
gonna have that same appreciation level
so you know I definitely have a high
appreciation level from suffering from
those consequences you know I'm saying
and um
I had to make a conscious decision like
I was saying
to either take music 110 and give it off
and leave that other [ __ ] alone which
was a very hard decision because I
wasn't in the best position financially
right and that easy money is easy money
right yeah and what you know is what you
know yeah and that's where the sacrifice
come in
you know and I made those sacrifices and
it was the best thing that I best
decision I made for my life you know
what I'm saying and I made it just by
having faith not really having a
complete understanding on how I was
going to capitalize and liquidate but I
knew the upside potential as opposed to
the upside of potential of the streets
right the potential is like short-term
gain but the long side the long-term
[ __ ] is jail death right incarceration
we know the results from that right it's
no it's not you know and you know the
short-term payoff is great yeah of
course of course you know what I'm
saying but
you know um that other life meaning like
the music and the music money just
seemed a little more intriguing and it's
not there's no uh there's really no one
way to do it and I feel like you've done
a great job of carving your own way of
making
like I feel like most artists look at
the music industry as okay I'm gonna get
in advance
I'm gonna put out music and I'm gonna
tour I'm gonna go do clubs I'm gonna do
shows as opposed to really turning over
every Rock if you have a core fan base
that's there's ways to monetize that it
really is and [ __ ] that's what see
if I was still in the streets I wouldn't
have magnified those opportunities but I
mean not being in the streets I've
really seen that and noticed it right so
it left when I was in the streets and
relying on other areas
you know it's easy to leave rocks
unturned you know what I'm saying so
it's like okay let me go in and figure
out how to make some money in this area
in this area in this area because it's
all I have yep I have no other way yeah
and sometimes you got to put yourself in
those positions to where all you got if
you were hustler then you got to put
yourself in a position to where you know
you have to hustle you got to look at
your product I mean as much as like it's
art but it's also like a business you're
in the music business and I feel like
especially as an independent artist it
almost expands the way you can make
money if you're assigned to a major
label there's so much red tape anything
you want to do as to where you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
you could drop a project for three
months before it hits dsps and only your
fans get it you could drop a [ __ ]
limited edition vinyl run you could do
so many things you could do that I
figured that out later on right but at
the beginning of the journey I don't
that's not too like you know visible for
us of course you know what I'm saying so
your first your goals change as you get
more knowledge and stuff at first I just
wanted to do yeah of course of course
yeah get your Advance get high defense
and stuff back then that was like
definitely still hard radio era that was
kind of the way to go back then it was
definitely the goal like and I didn't
understand that you know you didn't need
a lot of fans in order to really like
get rich facts you know you just need
you just need you need more fans and
followers I would take 500 fans over a
million followers I would definitely
take that because 500 fans when I say
fans of people who spend money with you
you're gonna be able to pay your bills
you'll be able to keep a roof over your
head with those 500 people if you do it
the right way of course yeah yeah of
course of course you've built weight I
mean you're you're up there man you're
killing it uh um but yeah it's wild
because I do feel like I I when I when
you talk to people who've been locked up
they take it as one or two ways either
one they come out and they're [ __ ]
more they're institutionalized or they
get humbled and they get it kind of
corrects the the path